justicia para George Floyd Estados
Unidos sentenció a 22 años por asesinar
a la afroamericano las imágenes de su
muerte dieron la vuelta al mundo en un
video amateur se vio a Floyd de
inmovilizado en el suelo diciendo
repetidamente No puedo respirar su
asaltante el policía chobin lo mantuvo
con su rodilla en el cuello durante
nueve minutos y 29 segundos
muy brevemente quiero dar mis
condolencias a la familia floyton
Espero que esto les dé un poco de
tranquilidad
el violento asesinato de Floyd provocó
protestas durante meses en todo Estados
Unidos contra la brutalidad policial y
la injusticia racial personalidades
afroamericanas como los Obama
reaccionaron a la condena hoy un Jurado
hizo lo correcto pero la verdadera
justicia requiere mucho más también lo
hizo Oprah winfrey aliviada y emocionada
de una manera que no esperaba lloré
Lágrimas de alegría mientras se leía
cada veredicto si en el proceso penal
chovin no reconoció a su estabilidad si
lo hizo en el litigio civil donde se
declaró culpable por primera vez de
violar los derechos civiles de Floyd
ciertamente hoy vimos un cierto nivel de
responsabilidad pero derecha también se
quedó con muy pocas opciones
se declaró culpable hoy después de
someter a esta familia a un juicio
desgarrador en el que el Jurado se dio
cuenta muy rápidamente de que él era
culpable de todos los cargos
policías estadounidenses han sido
acusados de homicidio contra
afroamericanos en varias ocasiones y en
la mayoría de los casos declarados
inocentes pero este no fue el caso de
Floyd donde la balanza de la justicia
estuvo de su lado